so I'm explaining the formula for
three-dimensional curl and where we left
off we have this determinant of a 3x3
matrix which looks absurd because none
of the individual components are actual
numbers but nevertheless I'm about to
show how when you kind of go through the
motions of taking a determinant you get
a vector valued function that
corresponds to to the curl so so let me
show you what I mean by that if you're
computing the determinant of the guy
that we have pictured there in the upper
right you start by taking this upper
left component and then multiplying it
by the determinant of the sub-matrix the
sub matrix whose rows are not the row of
I and whose columns are not the row of I
so what that looks like over here is
we're going to take that unit vector I
and then multiply it by a certain little
determinant and what this sub
determinant involves is multiplying this
partial partial Y by R which means
taking the partial derivative with
respect to Y of the multiply variable
function R and then subtracting off the
partial derivative with respect to Z of
Q so we're subtracting off partial
derivative with respect to Z of the
multi variable function Q and then that
so that's the first thing that we do and
then as the second part we take this J
and we're going to subtract off so
you're kind of thinking plus minus plus
for the elements in this top row so
we're going to subtract off J multiplied
by another sub determinant and then this
one is going to involve you know this
column that it's not part of in this
column that it's not part of and you
imagine those guys is a 2 by 2 matrix
and its determinant involves taking the
partial derivative with respect to X of
R so that's kind of the diagonal partial
partial X of R and then subtracting off
the partial derivative with respect to Z
of P so partial partial Z of P and then
that's just 2 out of 3 of the things we
need to do for our overall determinant
because the last part we're going to add
we're gonna add that top right component
K multiplied by the you know the sub
matrix whose columns involve the column
it's not part of and whose rows involve
the row that rows that it's not part of
so okay multiplied by the determinant of
this guy is going to be let's see
partial partial X of Q so that's partial
partial X of Q minus partial partial Y
of P so partial derivative with respect
to Y of the multivariable function P and
that entire expression is the
three-dimensional curl of the function
whose components are P Q and R so here
we have a vector function vector valued
function V whose components are P Q and
R and when you go through this whole
process of imagining the cross product
between the del operator this nabla
symbol and the the vector output P Q and
R what you get is this whole expression
and you know here we're writing it with
ijk notation if you were writing it as a
column vector I guess I didn't erase
some of these guys but if you were
writing this as a column vector it would
look like saying the curl of your vector
valued function V as a function of XY
and Z is equal to and then what I put in
for this first component would be what's
up there so that would be your your
partial with respect to Y of R minus
partial of Q with respect to Z so
partial of Q with respect to Z and I
won't copy it down for all of the other
ones but in principle you know you'd
kind of whatever this J component is and
I guess we're subtracting it so you'd
subtract there you'd copy that as the
next component and then over here but
oftentimes when you're computing curl
you kind of switch to using this ijk
notation my personal preference I
typically default to column vectors and
other people will write in terms of IJ
and K it doesn't really matter as long
as you know how to go back and forth
between the two one really quick thing
that I want to highlight before doing an
example of this is that the the K
component here the Z component of the
output is exactly the two dimensional
curl formula if you kind of look back to
the videos on 2d curl and what it's
formula is that is what we have here and
in fact all the other components kind of
look like mirrors of that but you're
using slightly different operators and
slightly different functions but if you
think about rotation that happens
in the xy-plane just two dimensional
rotation and how in three dimensions
that's described with a vector in the K
direction and again if that doesn't
quite seem clear maybe maybe look back
at the video on describing rotation with
a three-dimensional vector and the
right-hand rule but vector is pointing
in the P or z direction
describe rotation in the XY plane and
what's happening with these other guys
is kind of similar right rotation that
happens purely in the XZ plane is going
to correspond with a rotation vector in
the Y direction the direction
perpendicular to the X let's see so the
X Z plane over here and then similarly
this first component kind of tells you
all the rotation happening in the Y Z
plane and the vectors in the I direction
the the X direction of the output kind
of corresponds to rotation in that plane
now when you when you compute it you're
not always thinking about oh you know
this corresponds to rotation in that
plane and this corresponds to rotation
in that plane you're just kind of
computing it to get a formula out but I
think it's kind of nice to recognize
that all the intuition that we put into
the two-dimensional curl does show up
here and another thing I want to
emphasize is this is not a formula to be
memorized I would not if I were you try
to sit down and memorize this long
expression the only thing that you need
to remember the only thing is that curl
is represented as this del cross V this
nabla symbol cross product with the
vector valued function V because from
there whatever your components are you
can kind of go through the process that
I just did and the more you do it the
quicker it becomes it's kind of long but
it doesn't take that long and it's
certainly much more fault tolerant than
trying to remember something that has as
many moving parts as the formula that
you see here and and in the next video
I'll go through an actual example of
that oh I'll have functions for P Q and
R and walk through that process in a
more concrete context I'll see you then